I guess the question is if not Biden in  2024 not Harris who could it possibly be  I think it's honestly go be someone who  is just like Biden at the end of the day  they go make new promises say they're  gonna be something different it's gonna  be the same thing repeating Stacy Abrams  no no that's Michelle Obama and Oprah  both of them running on the same ticket  why wouldn't it happen tell me make an  argument I think that's who else is  there Gavin Newsom yeah but the serial  killer looking dude and then that crazy  woman which more uh which more I said  that by accident now I just kind of  realized  so seriously the The Butcher of the  nursing home uh people seriously who  else is there Pete budigen he's I mean  those are the only other two who did  judges and it has connections to  intelligence so he's going to be propped  up in there by the administration now  he's the biggest Megan McCain nah